we often see rocket labs rocket launches
recommended to us
on youtube and we see so-called electron
launches here and there
when we take a look at the upcoming
rocket launches on space flight now
aside from obviously being a rocket
company who exactly
is rocket lab what are their goals and
how much progress have they made
so far
well starting off rocket lab was started
way back
in 2006 by peter beck in auckland and
new zealand
before starting rocket lab peter had
been working at new zealand's industrial
research limited
as the name suggests industrial research
was a government-funded research
institution
aimed to promote scientific innovation
and subsequent
economic growth it's kind of like a
government-funded y combinator for
science and
technology anyways at industrial
research
peter found himself working on smart
materials as well super conductors
though he did decently enjoy his work
here peter says that he realized that
staying here would prevent them from
achieving his childhood dream
of working with rockets as he says quote
it's always been about the rocket
for me but just because he was all about
the rocket
didn't mean that he was insane just yet
at the time like the average person
interested in rockets
his goal was to simply join a large
rocket company
not start one himself as a result peter
would take up a month to go visit nasa
and talk to nasa engineers and rocket
scientists
though he approached opportunity with
great enthusiasm
as he got to know nasa's engineers his
conviction
of joining a large rocket company slowly
dwindled away
he later revealed that joining an
organization like nasa
would leave himself as a miniscule gear
of a giant machine
and he would have very little influence
in the overall project
after this quick realization peter
swiftly stepped into the crazy people
side
and decided that he was going to start
his own rocket company
fortunately for peter his time working
at industrial research
did not only provide him with the solid
science background
but even more importantly many key
connections
one such connection was a serial venture
capitalist named steven tyndall
the exact amount of money steven invests
in the company
is unknown but it is assumed to be in
the millions
if not tens of millions as steven has a
history of investing over 150 million
dollars
into various startups since then rocket
lab has also received a cool 25 million
dollars from the new zealand government
and another note of investors of course
lockheed martin
who is known to have poured significant
amounts of capital into rocket lab
with the foundation in place peter and
his team set on developing
the atelier 1. the atea 1 was
more of a proof of concept rocket and
was extremely small
the entire rocket was just 60 kilograms
and was capable of carrying just 2
kilograms to 150 kilometers
into the sky though this wasn't a
breakthrough rocket by any means
it did allow them to cautiously approach
developing bigger rockets
moreover it didn't take too long either
rocket lab was able to successfully
launch the tail 1
just a few years later in november of
which gave them the title of the first
private company to reach space
in the southern hemisphere during the
same time rocket lab was
also focused on fundraising as well and
i don't
mean just raising money through regular
old venture funding
but also by developing parts for other
aerospace companies
rocket lab developed systems for darpa
aeros rocketdyne and
lockheed martin in the early years but
as they built up sufficient funding
they stepped away from such projects
anyways
rocket lab was able to finally turn
their focus onto orbital class rockets
in 2010
after the operationally responsive space
office awarded them with a contract to
study low-cost small satellite launchers
rocket lab would subsequently spend
three years researching low-cost
small satellite launch solutions which
would ultimately lead them to the
electron program
in 2013. the electron orbital rocket was
a two-stage rocket
that utilized the rutherford engine
named after the famous new zealand-born
scientist
ernest rutherford though their naming
scheme would stay true to their new
zealand heritage
rocket lab would move their headquarters
from auckland new zealand to los angeles
california
however operations would continue in
auckland
as well following two years of
development
rocket lab would finally unveil the
electron rocket to the world in 2015
which would win them a 6.95 million
dollar contract from nasa
two more years later rocket lab would
finally be ready to put their electron
rocket to the test
with a test flight on may 25th 2017.
unfortunately however this test light
would never
reach orbit at the same time though the
launch
wasn't a large catastrophe either the
electron rocket would successfully
complete first stage burn
stage separation second stage ignition
and fearing separation
despite all of this the rocket did not
reach orbital velocity
but as i said though the rocket did not
succeed in accomplishing the final
desired result
the electron was successful at several
of the initial stages of the launch
and the test flight gave rocket lab a
plethora of data to work with
using this data and troubleshooting a
plethora of potential issues
rocket lab would set on a second flight
in january of 2018
which would be successful since then
rocket lab has successfully launched
several electron rockets into space and
that brings us to where we are
today electron seems cool and all
but what purpose does it exactly serve
in the market
well though you may not realize the
scale of the rocket when looking at
zoomed in shots of the rocket
the electron is actually super small for
example
take a look at the size comparison with
the space shuttle and falcon heavy
the electron is well below half of their
size
while that might seem like a
disadvantage at first glance
this is exactly what rocket lab has been
aiming for
they wanted to develop a small super low
cost rocket
that was still super powerful electron
is only capable of carrying 150
kilograms
into orbit but it can reach up to 500
kilometers
above sea level and the best part is
that each electron launch only costs 7.5
million dollars
which they're actually working on
driving down to 5 million
to put this in perspective a falcon 9
launch cost about 57 million dollars per
launch
now of course we also have to keep in
mind that falcon 9 can lift 22
800 kilograms into low earth orbit which
is 152 times the mass electron
is capable of carrying into low earth
orbit
at that rate it would cost 1.14 billion
dollars for rocket lab to deliver the
same payload into space
as a falcon 9 rocket so if you're a
large-scale satellite launcher
it doesn't make very much sense to go
with rocket lab
but that's okay rocket lab isn't
targeting this market
they're targeting companies that don't
need to deliver anywhere near
23 000 kilograms into space of course
spacex's rideshare program offers a
pretty good solution for some of these
companies
but some other companies have specific
specifications for the flight
that can only be met by dedicated rocket
launch
and in such scenarios it makes sense for
them to go to rocket lab to deliver
their payloads
into space so that's the current
position of
rocket lab within the space launch
market they're a niche player serving
the needs of small scale launchers with
specific needs
and requirements but what about the
future of a rocket lab
well rocket lab has been working on the
reusability of their orbital booster
until very recently all of rocket lab's
launches were fully expendable
thus requiring a brand new rocket for
each launch
however since 2019 the company has been
working on making the majority of their
rocket
reusable in fact just last week
rocket lab succeeded in recovering their
first lockdown booster after parachuted
into the ocean moving forward however
the method they're planning to use to
recover boosters
is quite unconventional they're not
looking to land their booster like
spacex does
nor dump it into the ocean and then fish
it out like they just did
rather they want the booster to pressure
down just like we saw this time
but instead of letting it dive into the
ocean rocket lab is looking to send out
a helicopter that will snatch the
parachute
and thus the booster as well and fly it
to the desired location
this is quite a unique approach and may
very well be possible with their booster
given the much smaller size aside from
this
rocket lab has also been harder work
developing
and testing 3d printed engines to
drastically reduce cost
in fact last year the company reached
its 100th 3d printer rutherford engine
but looking past reducing the cost of
spaceflight through improving
reusability
and creating cheaper parts rocket lab
doesn't actually have
any known super ambitious goals such as
reaching the moon
or mars or even providing super fast
point-to-point travel
within the earth taking a look at their
company mission
it's pretty straightforward and modest
rocket lab aims to create a new era of
small satellite launch technology
by reducing cost and increasing
frequency by accomplishing this
they hope to help companies students
scientists
and researchers learn and understand
space better
quite the stark contrast between musk's
vision of terraforming mars
or beta's vision of off-planet in all
manufacturing and energy production
or even richard branson's vision of
providing space tourism
from what we know about rocket lab today
it's not clear if they're even looking
to ever get into crude flights
at all it looks like peter just really
liked rockets and wanted to work on
rockets
and so he created a relatively small
niche rocket company
that fulfills longing for rocket science
truly
a refreshingly modest vision in an
industry filled with high hopes
and massive dreams where do you guys
think rocket lab is headed
comment that down below also drop a like
if you guys love seeing competition
in the space market and of course
consider joining our discord community
to suggest future video ideas
and consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered
but until then i'm hari and i'll see you
guys
on the next one